Nick Kroll and John Mulaney yes they're
both brilliant standards I'm promoting
oh hello on Broadway it's now through
January the 15th at the Lyceum Theatre
it's on West 45th Street yes
oh hello broadway.com if you want
tickets these shows do sellout I got to
see it on Broadway it seemed like just
did major it just felt like an
accomplishment to see this show get put
on on Broadway because you could tell it
was something that Nick and John who
really wanted to put on and put all this
time and it must have been hard to get
made and the fact that it was shown on
Broadway and everything I was then
people were laughing in the audience and
enjoying it was uh it was it was cool to
see welcome guys what's up guys all
right guys how you doing we're good we
were in the room when you were saying
all those nice things yes uncomfortable
by minute 45 Wow just ask them how they
did it we said we had Jim Norton on the
show off Broadway that's how we did it
that's how we got that's right it's true
at the Cherry Lane yeah that's amazing
it was a fun show to do
is it I was thinking about that the fact
that one of the segments in the play has
a different interview guest and I feel
like if I was putting on a play I
wouldn't want the extra stress of also
having to book a guest for every night
you don't mean yeah it's probably pretty
similar to what you guys do it you just
deal with you do your show and then you
have this element of guests and people
coming in you sort of host them and you
sort of just move on and keep doing the
show yeah do you like because it keeps
it fresh I get stand-ups it's kind of
hard to W we do the same thing every
night but this is kind of harder to go
off-book if you're in a script we have
we have a good amount of improvising
just in the rest of the play but the
interview does make it like does make it
fresh and also helps like place the show
in time you know cause like you're doing
the same thing every night and then
you're doing the same thing twice on
Saturday twice on Sunday and there is a
weird thing where you're like in the
middle of the play and I'll think like
what day is it I'm like where are we
like how many times have we done this
like you just done it a million times
right usually directly I mean at least
go like that was the night Seth Rogen
came that was the night Stephen Colbert
gay right
and Ryan John and also John's getting
very good at dropping the names of the
people who've done the show so
you know what that's not funny you know
what that's not funny to accuse me of
being obnoxious okay when I'm trying to
publicize okay okay let's just do it
let's talk about other stuff right let's
do our personas that were like each
other do you do you worry though with
the guests like the people have you have
you gone Devi done any shows where
people are disappointed because you say
like yeah Seth Rogen was here now and
all that was here and then somebody
comes on who's a star but they're not
Alan Alda yeah I think people have an
expectation sometimes you if you call if
you introduce someone and they're like
no that's not the most famous person in
the world I know I experienced that
walking out on stage I've seen those
blank uncomfortable stares like it was
amazing like I went to SNL a few weeks
ago and Emily Blunt and Bruno Mars were
there yeah and like while that's
happening the thing comes up on the
screen that says next week Lady Gaga and
Tom Hanks and the audience audibly went
oh yeah because they were like there but
they're more famous than the people that
we busy it is it can happen that way I
think I mean the truth is like we've had
guests who are I mean you have very
famous people and then they're not
actually fun and very quickly the
audience forgets who they're you know
once you get past like ladies and
gentlemen John Mulaney people are bummed
out about that then you uh
once you're there up on stage you start
a realize I'm not gonna do time they're
there right never there not ever after
both divorced um like Robin Bird perfect
example yeah every person in the theatre
knew who Robin Byrd was even though she
is Jim do you know Robin Bertus I know
the name but I don't know what she does
hmm really
that's so you didn't grow up in New York
City right I grew up in Jersey yeah what
Jonathan bird to Robin bird it hosted a
cup cable-access show that interviewed
porn stars and strippers yeah yeah III
know the name I didn't yes Reggie and al
goldstein brought a [ __ ] short uh case
against the Supreme Court about not
against the Supreme Court no they went
they want to do this yeah yeah bird all
the scene v Supreme Court or the
Thurgood Marshall into retirement
they wanted to take over as the gist to
justice yeah but nobody people didn't
exactly know who she was and then or
some people did that people who grew up
like you know you know isolate come into
New York City and like go to my friend's
house and watch Robin Byrd and like see
her interview like strippers and porn
stars it was amazing people didn't quite
know she was but then once you get into
the interview it then it's just super
fun and interesting talking to this
woman who's been and done and seeing
everything and everyone I we also bring
people up from the audience sometimes as
a guest and I guess where those those
are the best interviews they are right
they're not people who used to being
interviewed yeah yeah nothing to protect
and everybody's and everybody's
discovering this person together so like
we John picked a guy out of the crowd
last week and we brought him up music on
mustache and he gets on stage and and
we're like original is his right before
the election he's from Ohio from
Defiance Ohio and then but it was then
realized that he lives in New York and
he's a cop in New York who cop who works
in like Community Relations it was just
a super interesting guy to talk to my PD
community outreach to bridge the gap
between people in cops so it's like our
characters it was like he had two deals
with guys like us all day long right
complaining about like you know the you
know Gestapo tactics but then also
freaked out like a white person you guy
came to yeah so it they're all they all
end up fun as long as we have details as
long as the person's willing to talk to
us right I get Alan Alda he seem like
he's hard to get to do things he's older
you know yeah we eventually we've been
after for years we've been trying to get
him for Kroll show we've been trying to
get him for a lot of stuff and then I
think I honestly think it was Louie's
show yeah he had connections through to
horse and peat through the yeah through
horse and peat and guy named Dave Becky
and it so I think we just we just worked
it through that and then he had heard
about a word Broadway helped yes you're
opposed to like do you want to meet two
Muppets yeah yeah I guess it's different
than trying to do your podcast right
mm-hmm
uh it did before um yeah we got some
momentum in the beginning though it was
like it's called oh hello on Broadway we
want you to do a segment called too much
tuna by the way my name is John is there
we don't play John and Nick we play old
men you'll get served tuna fish do you
want to do this yeah a lot of people
were just sort
I don't know we're talking about it took
like you know you show you get a little
press about people doing it and help who
are the most nervous to have on there
must have been somebody who like one of
you really looked up to Marcia Clark
Marcia Clark's the OJ yeah he did it her
yes I don't know what he was on amazing
yeah
oh sorry David Byrne - yeah we had David
Byrne from the Talking Heads and and
much more this past weekend which I get
I blew his intro really bad because I
was so nervous yeah would you do I was
just I was like he's an acclaimed
composed I started using any claim on
composer he's complained he's complained
and I went I went like a claim complaint
complain a claim he's the founder
there's also great David my work the
character you're doing is playing an old
man it's like you're playing it I know
that is the event broke through or
you're like this young man is [ __ ]
panicking yeah so why Marcia Clark well
you know she seems like she'd be fairly
easy to talk to she was really easy to
talk to is I was actually most nervous
when I had to call her and explain the
bit to her I'm obsessed with the OJ
trial and yet I didn't know how to what
to say I'm like do you say I'm a big fan
right like I don't know what I admire
your lack of ability to get it done yeah
I admire her ability some you know I was
like hey yeah I just I I started
spinning Nick has a photo of me talking
around them I went I I believe you
already was that thing like when like
high school students give a speech and
they use too many words
yeah we are already at the point where
we are trying to talk to you it was just
like it was spinning out of control that
was the sweetest though she's nice she
was awesome really cool he's awesome
should we talk to her about like Cochran
and like this is before the show the
show would come out but the documentary
hadn't come out people the FX show was
airing at that time but not the 34:30
yeah yeah but it was it was really cool
and then and I mean they're all I mean
Alan Alda was pretty nerve-wracking that
was that was our first show David Byrne
it's a lot of the folks who are also
like we I saw f murray abraham who you
would know from like homeland now yeah
and scarface salieri and mozart and I
saw him on the street he plays a he's
referenced in our show
and and he's like a major plot point in
the show but you never see him and I saw
him on the street and I was like hey we
do this show it's called oh hello and we
have this bit where you you get
reference but we never see you we would
you like to do it and he was like but
I'm I don't understand what do you want
me to do and I was like well we would if
we don't see you on the show but we'd
like you to do it he's like so in a way
I'm already doing my job say I'm going
to come out and then I don't come out
I'm already doing but it's it's really
fun specifically the people who don't
have a ton of reference point for who we
are what we do but at the same time it's
also like Birbiglia did the show the
other night and we've John and Mike and
I've known each other for you know
however long we've all known each other
like almost 20 years so at that point
you then have like three old friends on
stage right yeah oh we had Ray Kelly on
the off-broadway version former
policeman yes and it's one of those
things where I was nervous about
offending him with language you know
really he's like the former police
commissioner right he probably used a
little bit language also seen everything
yeah I'm like heads blown open so he's
not like offended are you a true crime
like fanatic or is it just the oth are
you do like a true I like a true crime
is that why you want to Ray casting
appointment yes why you want Ray Kelly
well act what Ray Kelly we just wanted
is like quintessential New York he's a
and he of funny was had been a beat cop
on the Upper West Side so he'd been
dealing with [ __ ] like our
characters is his whole career but it's
more honestly for us it's almost it's
just the idea of someone who does some
we had a fun Alex Cornish Shelley
Shelley who's on like chopped and an
Iron Chef it's just fun to touch people
in order you know at other kind who have
other kinds of gigs besides just
comedians and act absolutely who you not
able to get the even trying to get
there's got to be one guy that you
really want but it's just too busy the
rock with we have a standing offer to
Steely Dan yes we've been answered miss
Healy Jan Donald Fagen and
in and Walter Becker are referenced a
ton in our show so you did defends the
Dan out there yeah um you know get on
social media cuz you know there's a
change.org petition to get Steely Dan
back to the streets yeah do you worry
when you're on stage that like because
there's there's so many reverences like
there's a lot of the show that I feel
like the humor relates directly to a
Broadway crowd yes cuz like there's
there's inside Broadway jokes yes
there's also a bunch of inside Steely
Dan Joe yes like you worry you're gonna
be in front of a crowd that is not on
the inside of that stuff and we've yet
to meet a crowd that's completely in the
pocket with the Steely Dan stuff yeah
but that's good at people at people
respect that you know something about
something people respect specific yeah
they like they're like you guys they
don't care about Steely Dan even though
I don't know like I haven't read the
liner notes to Gaucho yes guys really
huge Steely Dan fans where I wasn't yeah
I'm a fan of Steely Dan I think John's a
massive fan yeah I see them every year
at the Beacon that we couldn't go this
year cuz this stupid Broadway show you
just sit at home like listening to
Steely Dan and watching all day to the
OJ trial yes yeah I like that I like a
guy with hobby that happened yeah I
think that's good it's genuinely true
what about the og trial fast nature oh I
just remember it's so visceral from
growing up and I don't know my family
debated OJ for like dirt all throughout
the trial literally it was all the
mulaney's versus OJ yeah we had a civil
suit against taking up a lot of our time
yeah remember my mom would watch me suck
at basketball and she'd be sitting in
the stands with a Walkman on the side so
when they were debate would say your dad
died like you know everyone thought he
was guilty yeah it was whether my
parents are lawyers and they were like
judge Ito should be clearing the court
you would never allow that how I said my
dad had worked for a judge and judge
Weinfeld and you always go weinfeld
would never stand for this no they the
kind where they both criminal attorneys
were civil or and my mom's a law
professor at Northwestern University and
my dad is a corporate attorney but they
both went to law school and like to talk
about everything yeah it also is just I
don't know it's just the most I mean why
did we all watch that 3430 it's the
I trust me I only ask you completely
fascinated in a silo GLA in the night I
liked JaVale a Indies is that no hate
it's great to say la foot into the 90s
and like everyone but restaurants yeah
those like metaluna like those
restaurants and like where it was like
people were like Westwood is the coolest
neighbor dang out and yeah a lot of big
shoulder pads Laurel time so what did
they think of did they think Marcia
Clark did a good job or they think she
didn't Chris Darden they must have been
like oh they weren't that they weren't
like Monday morning quarterbacks about
uh all that stuff I'm trying to remember
it was mainly about Edo they didn't like
him they were like that is not how you
run a courtroom right well historically
and it worked out yeah he's not a great
judge no it's really the whole world
really banished the most one of the most
watched the this the first time the
whole planet got to see a trial yeah
yeah the most watched a lot of pressure
to not [ __ ] up any [ __ ] up yeah also
it he filled a room right here yeah
weird
improved the idea of the whole world
watching right yeah and then he would
it's just like unprecedented to give
like these little soliloquies about
what's happening as the judge pretty
they're letting the Anna Nicole Smith
judge judge Larry Sadler
yeah I favorite judges cuz they just
would talk emotionally about what was
happening over time I think there are a
lot of judges that are like a lot of
doctors who have these like God
complexes to get to stand up in front of
people and they're the ones or you say
what goes I guess also like religious
people like or if you like I feel like
half the rabbi's in the country we're
like wanted to be actors and they're
like mmm I think I'll be a rabbi and
I'll have a captive audience yeah I
don't know if it's the same with like
with like priests and I think you're
like southern precinct I gotta open with
they gotta open with a joke yeah same as
any Moyles
the guys who do the circumcision always
are doing she'd never been to a dress
that didn't have seven minutes of
material yeah really yeah yeah yeah I
went to one purse I can't go back it was
so uncomfortable norm son it freaked me
out I wasn't used to hearing a baby cry
like that like yeah just uh really
actually that's my ringtone [ __ ]
animal wailing of the voice
I had a bris where we were all like back
against the wall because no one wanted
to look
uh-huh and the moil kept being like come
on gather I had from my my best friend
from childhood I held his like I you
know they they give a little wine to the
baby to like to do nominal yeah and I
was holding like the gauze of wine in
the baby's mouth and like had a
bird's-eye view of the like that ah the
[ __ ] operation horrible it was it was
a real trip yeah it was really really uh
and then I did it to myself well John
had did you know John married a Jewish
woman so he did itself did you do a self
circumcision or yeah there's a kit you
can do it at home right do you break the
glass then you pick up the glass and you
just take care of it right and groomed
apart and I you there's this little kit
and yeah so you can do you convert no I
didn't know article yeah it's always
weird to me no they say often talking
meaning when people are religious and it
goes both ways where like one has to
cook I know a Jewish girl and she's want
to get married but she has to marry a
Jewish guy and she wants him to convert
and like there's so much to that who
gives if I know and and then she'll and
then she'll get old enough where she
doesn't carry maybe not yeah cuz it's a
just marry a good guy you know an
[ __ ] who converts or a nice guy who
what did you did she ask you to you
decided well no she was raised
culturally Jewish but no we were married
by a comedian we didn't have a real
imagine dan levy who's got a special out
honesty Cheyenne on seeso coming out
today wow that worked well I know this
now Dan owes me I know but uh but yeah
but he he did your wedding but but your
family was Catholic yeah we grew up were
the most Irish Catholic people DG wasn't
important three the one of you guys it's
it's important for my family but the
older I get I wanted both families
equally yeah and for me I think at this
point my parents are just like the idea
that I would marry someone would be
exciting for them they want you every
cause you they've given up I'm Joe
Pesci's mom and good girl yeah I'm with
it live live I got a woman every night
mom yeah yeah when everyone comes over
and she cooks some cooks at John late
meals why don't you find a nice girl
yeah um but di no I think they would
just be psyched if I got married but I
don't have as much pressure there's um
there's four I'm the youngest four kids
and they all all my siblings
for me kids so there's 12 have you come
close no not really
yeah I mean you know nah man never
engaged never lived with a woman like
I've dated long-term a few years but
it's never been like oh this is the one
yeah you don't have it you don't have
like a philosophical aversion to it you
just kind of heaven yeah I kind of want
a relationship at this point I'm not
pushing you don't think you'd ever get
married I'm not saying I'm a really if I
love somebody enough why not it's like
I've seen single life for 48 years right
yeah yeah I need to look for right right
well would end you and Sam I mean
nothing no not at all I mean we took off
on a cracker once in a while right over
here yes get over get this snake over
here yeah that's like a family yeah yeah
run it for sign of his video it
literally is great laters everyone the
parents dump all this [ __ ] on you and
you have to eat it yeah yeah exactly
right did you guys grow up like theater
fans does that really did I brought up
before but that struck me when I was
watching this show was like these guys
know a lot about Broadway yeah I mean I
grew up in Chicago but there's a ton of
theater from the Goodman to the
Steppenwolf in Second City and there's
lots of smaller smaller theaters there
also everything from Broadway either
will preview there or tour there pretty
quickly and I was a theater usher at the
big theaters where Broadway shows would
come oh wow yeah and I like I mean I did
some plays I liked plays all right I
mean honestly it's both it's a weird
thing cause it's both as we say like a
love letter to theater but also like a
stalkers note written and lipstick on a
mirror it's like a you know there's a
lot of the things about plays and stuff
that we can't stand about plays yeah and
that's I think what I think helps
audiences because like you know if
you're not a theater fan if you go
you're like oh I've seen that that's one
of the things I [ __ ] hate in a play
yeah II hate in play I mean fake smoking
fake smoking is annoying people you ever
even have you at mean has anyone as it's
about 17 years yeah as anyone who smokes
in a play ever smoked a real cigarette
looks like smoke arrabal up they hold it
like they're in a 40s movie we do it in
the show but like one sided phone calls
you know or like a phone call and you
have to repeat all the information so
that the audience knows what the other
person's with
their line is saying oh yeah um I mean
it's just like also being in the crowd
being in the audience is sitting next I
was at a play and I watched this woman
open up a Tupperware of blueberries or
like a plastic thing from the front and
she started eating them and you could
hear the plastic and it was like all
right that's fine and then I saw guys
sitting on the aisle and opposite her
older guy getting so annoyed at her
eating the blueberries and then I
couldn't stop watching him nudge his
wife and get pissed off about that
because so it's you know for me it's
like it's the experience partly it's
experience of going to a play what's it
like to be in the crowd what's it like
to be on stage and and acknowledge like
to me it's just my issue with theatres
how embarrassing it is for everybody to
pretend like the two people on stage are
in a Chinese restaurant
we're always [ __ ] theater together
like that right I remember in college
being second row watching a good friend
of mine pretend to be FDR that was just
like what this you're not FDA at every
play I'm I just what we just saw the
front page which is a great great play
but it's set in the 1928 and it starts
with this big news room for the
old-timey guys and I just wanted I like
I still wanted to just walk out on stage
in a hoodie and be like hey everyone
knock it off yeah I thought I was
telling him before I like some plays I
see but I don't love the idea of a live
play and you know like musicals - yeah I
know I don't I don't like there's
something about it maybe that's what it
is we all know what's going on I even
felt that way about sketch when I would
move to the city and was doing like
improv and sketch and stand-up like I
had to stop doing sketch because I
couldn't stand the idea of being on
stage and not being able to acknowledge
the audience a bit didn't work not being
able like so what we started doing we
actually started doing these characters
off ten years ago at a at Rififi in the
East Village and it was it was partly so
that we could acknowledge that we were
in a [ __ ] room with people where that
didn't work we were all weren't doing
like little pee it just drove me it just
made me uncomfortable that's the best
part of stand-up is acknowledging it's
it feels alive like if something flops
you just talk about yes some make some
noise yeah you mention it's really hard
to not mention what that guy was falling
asleep during the show a couple nights
ago and I just started throwing Swedish
fish at
like up he did not I mean the guy was
whipping him atom in the whole crowd was
laughing and ever like we're all like
wake up and he would not wake in 1987
great story that yeah he was like a
young that's a thing it wasn't like an
older gentleman it was like a young guy
and like a hoodie and and John correctly
like and we can we can reference and we
start to you know get that in the show
said he looked like Vincent van Gogh if
he did devil sticks yeah he had like a
little red beard and he looked like a
bum and I grew swedish fish and and then
we just were like figured he was on
methadone he really had that methadone
and then more of an odd often yeah is
the second row and like that's not an
inexpensive ticket right the whole
picture made no sense when you're when
you're Nick I guess specifically when
you're so used to like writing
characters that are quick yeah I mean
for like crawl shows or is it difficult
to then go forward and be like we're
gonna right this minute show no yes and
no I mean in this particular case I
think the reason we settled on not
settled on we took we we were interested
in doing these guys in a broader format
is because we've you know accumulated
like 10 years of bits on them it's like
almost like an old vaudeville act like
you have a bag of bits that you can pull
out and so we have that and then also
it's just we they're such specific men
that all it just was giving it all we
need to do is take the time to focus on
like their backstory figure out where
they were from and it and it started to
write itself and expand itself out
pretty quickly just because we already
there was already a ton of information
on them I don't know if all the
characters would have worked like right
it makes sense that you could actually
do it long for me do you guys now at
this point what you just show up at the
theater like right before I would
imagine that because my wife Anna is our
makeup artist and all quarters advisor
we do like let's say we each do like 40
minutes and make it yeah it's good
amount of makeup to make us look like we
can get in there you know we get there
we're still changing jokes and we're
still messing around so we sit there and
just talk over what we want to do that
night yeah it's them it's kind of the
most fun version of for for me at least
I've like what you always hoped show
business would be which is like you go
to your theater you in it and then in
this case it's like we've got each other
to sort of go through and talk about
bits that we want to change and tweak
and then all of a sudden you have this
guests come in and
they join you and you you know you have
this sort of unique to the night
experience and then maybe go you know go
to have a drink or a restaurant
afterwards it just feels like you're
like oh like back when you thought about
like what show business was yeah it's
kind of a today you have free and then
you go do it at night yeah and then it's
like we have it's like it's like having
you know all told over ten years we have
like three hours of jokes that we can
interchange right and you also get to
share the stage which is so fun cuz at
times when you can just stop talking
yeah that's a bummer oh stand up as
you're just like [ __ ] I don't feel it
tonight or I'm like you and you don't
have anyone to be like can you just
handle the next five minutes yeah it's
very difficult sometimes when you don't
want to do it you're like oh man I got
45 to go yeah [ __ ] me yeah yeah I'm and
I can't stop talking yeah yeah enjoy
making each other break yes
noticing that one did you ever see on
Carol Burnett with Harvey Korman and Tim
cow have you ever seen one fear that is
art that is sort of our fear is that
like you know like in you know common I
think comedians and folks are like oh
look at them look at them break how
[ __ ] but John genuinely makes me
laugh every night any fake breaking I'm
doing things to disrupt the show to make
him money yes right and the audience's
in the audience's do enjoy and then the
audience makes me laugh right because we
were about to say our final lines of the
show which are you know sort of like in
a spotlight very emotional all quiet
music playing and this woman just went
but dude yeah and I laughed so yeah it's
true
is it nice to have the freedom to laugh
it [ __ ] up that's so great ho-yang a
dramatic piece that's crazy
we set the tone early in the show that
this is not a professional effort they
want me to get used to it well you can
all go see it if you go - oh hello
broadway.com you get tickets it's at the
Lyceum theater which is on 45th Street
and it's only playing through January
5th jit emoni I saw it really I did it's
a really great show Jim no it's great
man you can get rush tickets if you go
to the theater on day of day of yes
expensive so go get tickets thank you
guys very much for being here thanks for
I am dad yeah well can we just quickly
talk about Scientology for 45 minutes
I'm doing a documentary